the Philippines has a drug problem a big
one their war on drugs has led to a
brutal and bloody crackdown by police
and vigilante groups leaving almost
2,000 dead without charge or trial in
just two months and the u.s. just
promised thirty two million dollars to
the Philippines to help win the fight
against drugs but what exactly will that
money be supporting drugs are a big
business in the Philippines it's been
that way for decades but the country's
new president Rodrigo Duterte has made
it his mission to change it even if it
takes extreme measures the Philippines
has the highest usage rates of
methamphetamines in Southeast Asia
locally the drug is referred to as shabu
the country also plays a major role in
the global drug trade
so why the Philippines well it's all
about location materials from China and
India are imported by Chinese syndicates
then made into methamphetamine and
redistributed and drugs from as far away
as Africa and Mexico have been
transported through the country entered
to tear tape during his 20 years as
mayor of Davao he fought crime and drugs
using unorthodox techniques that some
compared to those of a police state
human rights groups say that he used
armed death squads to hunt down
suspected criminals when running for
president Duterte said he'd order police
to shoot to kill
suspects of organized crime he's also
said he would protect civilians who
engage in violence because you are doing
your duty and I will protect you and he
has there are nighttime raids by police
and vigilante groups who pull people out
of their homes and sometimes shoot them
on sight kill lists of those allegedly
involved in a drug trade are distributed
and since police and vigilantes are free
to respond with deadly force
the accused don't get to argue their
innocence in courts the results in the
first seven weeks since his term started
at the end of June at least 1,700 people
were killed in the streets by police or
vigilantes who say they were part of the
drug trade but families and human rights
groups say that at least some of the
victims were in fact innocent people
mistaken for criminals because of his
reputation Duterte is known as the
Punisher but he has a lot of support
from Filipinos who want to see their
country cleaned up opinion polls show
90% of citizens support is tactics but
the UN and the US State Department have
criticized the extra legal killings we
strongly urge the Philippines to ensure
its law enforcement efforts comply with
its human rights obligations in response
to territory threatened to withdraw from
the UN but US Secretary of State John
Kerry still promised the Philippines
millions of dollars for training police
in the war on drugs so should the u.s.
be helping fund doterra today's campaign
of fear